hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu ziehen das ganze
irgendeinen japan heute mein magen
knurren deswegen ein japanisch
chinesisches spiel wird sich bei denen
gesehen habe ich fand sehr witzig in
amerika nach day kurzen ist genau mein
ding deswegen ist dass ich angeblich der
falling foul
wir können entweder auf gamestar oder
ranking klicken wir klicken einfach auf
gamestar
wie soll man irgendwie schlau werden
daraus ich kann also mit space irgendwas
machen und mit der linken taste davon
wir starten einfach das geld wir stehen
hier in einer botox das war laut wir
stehen hier in einer bushaltestelle
geboren video vorbei wir sehen uns ich
stehe an dieser bushaltestelle und wenn
ich
was habe ich jetzt mit der taste gemacht
mit linksklick mache ich hier
schon wieder game over das ist auch so
kann man seine leistung in solchen
spielen sind unfassbar und einfach nur
krieg dieses kleine ding da unten das
ist eine notlösung quasi den kann ich
immer einsetzung den großen kurz darf
ich nur einsetzen wenn ihnen welche
kraft karten kommen zum beispiel 220
punkte 270 punkte game over dokumenten
highscore ich wollte mich gerade als
highschool luca pups nennen das ist
allerdings nicht möglich deswegen hat
sich jetzt lukas er kommt nicht zum
akinator ehrlich freunde wirklich ich
habe immer das gefühl wenn ich irgend
etwas neues erfinden das ist direkt
kommen 90 kommentare kommen so ist es
schon mal macchina tor ja ich weiß
gleich ein und ich denke dann immer so
jahr dadurch dass ihr das ein recht
wollte ja nur dass ich ein video darüber
mache und ich will nicht als auch durch
haben hört auf alles einzureichen bitte
jimi blue ochsenknecht dann haben wir
hier
flipper dann haben wir noch einfach ingo
flamingo und wir haben hier natürlich
auch noch fremd jedenfalls habe ich da
hat vier neue charaktere erfunden und
die sind alle schon mal akinator wurden
alle schon hundertfach gespielt jetzt
okay wie don't have a beast okay ich
habe auf jeden fall luca und kann was
von dem bestätige und was ist canceln
schon einmal den unteren das heißt war
wohl richtig spiel ist übrigens aus dem
jahr 2004
hier ist einfach zwölf jahre her
ich bin nicht mal zwölf jahre alt und
jetzt wieder
ich weiß gar nicht was ist denn
überhaupt mein ziel
ich glaube mein ziel ist dass sich
letztendlich auf den grünen statt wo was
ist das denn
ich glaube ich muss nachher auf den
blauen status unten sein geht nicht man
kann nicht leise kurzen will ich
schreibe es geht nicht und es kommt sg
ist unmöglich
man kommt nicht weg bei diesen orangenen
ich bin im grünen rat gewesen
ich will nur einmal den dunkelgrünen
bereits ich bin gerührt gewesen nein ich
hasse das kann nicht sein
das beste sind immer diese dicken
gabelstapler die ab und zu vorbeikommt
kann man am meisten punkte raus stellen
anstatt wer diesen anderen komischen
kaffee gibt mehr über den beruf und ich
bin bei null
ich bin beim eishockey nur das ist mein
bester aller zeiten freunde ich kann es
vielleicht schaffen jetzt neuen
highscore zu stellen das ist unfassbar